bad boys bad boys what you gonna do what
you gonna do
[Music]
Matt you always talk about how shopping
cart ditchers are Psychopathic monsters
but what other small infractions
indicate that someone is literally a
Nazi I have one bumper Riders people who
ride your bumper in traffic should be
excommunicated from Earth I could not
disagree more with you Candace I'm
afraid in fact you are the one who
should be excommunicated and banned from
the show obviously because if you're if
you're I don't have this problem with
people riding my bumper do you know why
because I keep up with the speed of
traffic and I'm not going to be in the
fast lane going you know 60 miles an
hour I realize that if you're in the
fast lane on the highway you need to be
going at least 25 miles over the over
the limit at least to justify being in
the fast lane
um so I don't I know I don't have this
issue if you have this issue it means
that you are driving too slow
I'm an Unapologetic bumper writer
because uh because it's just my way of
communicating to you that you need to
speed up or move over
how else am I going to communicate it
so yes there are other seemingly small
infractions that indicate that someone
is literally a Nazi
and driving too slow is one of those
things unfortunately Candace
you are a Nazi and banned from the show
what you want
this is important that I talk to you
about this you guys know how I feel
about cyclists
I am uh not a fan of cyclists at all and
here is we have the tweet from
um someone put out okay here it is
Jeremy Vine
I don't know who that is exactly
but he's got a big following so he's a
well-known guy
he put out a tweet a couple of days ago
with a video of cyclists on a back
Country Road and they're not they're not
like lined up one by one in single file
line there's there's four or five of
them across taking up the entire Lane
and Jeremy Vine says people who cycle in
the country should be encouraged to ride
two three and four abreast like this for
the following reasons one it calms the
traffic behind them and makes it less
easy for bad drivers to attempt
dangerous passes
three it's more pleasant and sociable
for them
all right let me tell you if you're a
cyclist
as a as a motorist myself
let me give you the scoop
um it absolutely does not calm the
traffic behind you when you're holding
us all up we are not we are not calm
behind you you might be calm and having
a nice time we are not we're very angry
um and it doesn't make passing you
easier or less dangerous when we can't
see as well about what's in front of of
you
and as far as it being more pleasant and
sociable it might be but let me tell you
something else we don't give a damn
if your ride is pleasant and sociable as
I tweeted back to this guy I said nobody
gives a damn if you're right is pleasant
and sociable you roadway parasite get
out of the way
you know I I think I have a really
[Music]
gentle way of going about these things
don't I
you are you're like a barnacle you're a
parent or something worse than that
you're you're a parasitic infants
infestation of the roadway
oh it's a pleasant and and and sociable
ride that's not what the road is for it
is there for cars to get from point A to
point B
that's why it's there
you want Pleasant and sociable go on a
bike path in the woods
okay or go to the gym and get on a
stationary bicycle and sit next to
someone you can have all the
conversation be as pleasant and sociable
as you want
there are places for that the road is
not a recreational place
there are places for recreation the road
is not one of them
it's like I said before it would it I
see no difference between this and me
like
um taking a game of of
taking a board game and just putting it
in the middle of the road and sitting
around
with some people and playing a board
game that's Pleasant it's sociable it's
how I like to enjoy myself it's a
recreational activity
there's a time and place where the road
is not that
it wasn't made for you I got news for
you
the road was made these paved roads okay
the cars go on they were made
specifically for cars that's why they're
there
are places made for you it's not the
road
uh and someone I also want to show you
this do we have someone else where
someone responded to me on Twitter and I
was just trying to make sense of this
this is someone who's a cyclist and they
were very upset at what I said calling
you know all I did was call cyclist
roadway parasites I don't see the big
deal but he said eat crap and die
apiarist scum
I gotta say that is the first time I've
ever heard that phrase apiary apiarist
is a beekeeper which I am well I'm a
beekeeper in spirit right now because
when we moved I had to give away all the
bees unfortunately but in my heart I'm
still a beekeeper once a beekeeper
always a beekeeper
um this is a level of hostility towards
beekeepers that I have never seen before
apiarist scum
was this guy like some super villain
from Captain Planet
he's got some sort of plot to destroy
all the bees in the world for no reason
very strange lots of anger on Twitter
and again I don't know what I did to
provoke it all I said was all I did was
call people parasites that's it
I'm gonna be very Petty granted this
segment is almost always Petty you know
I really could call the segment five
minutes of pettiness and I would
probably capture the spirit of what I'm
doing here but any case I I'm feeling
especially Petty today after driving
into work this morning
and the problem with driving to work
every morning is that I live in
Nashville
and though the people of Nashville are
wonderful in many ways they are not
wonderful on the road this town is
populated by all of the world's worst
drivers I don't know if bad drivers come
here so that they so that they can be
with their own kind maybe Nashville has
become something of a mecca for
incompetent motorists they come here on
pilgrimages many Die along the way
or maybe after coming here good drivers
become bad
is there something in the water
is there something in the Tennessee
whiskey
and I suppose there probably definitely
is something the whiskey that would make
you a bad driver maybe I've just solved
the riddle I don't know this is a
question for psychiatrists and
anthropologists to study all I know is
that as I drive into Nashville
I get a literal front row seat to
witness every bad driving habit every
single morning ramped up by a factor of
10. so just to give you an example of
the kind of thing you might encounter as
you travel the highways and byways of
our lovely town
I have on multiple occasions witness
people Screech to a halt on the highway
I mean a dead stop from 70 to zero
so they don't miss their exit I saw a
guy once blow past his exit Screech to a
stop drive onto the shoulder and reverse
on the shoulder back to his exit
I witnessed this because I was the guy
right behind him the guy who if not for
my own incredible skill I'm the only
skilled driver in the entire state by
the way if not for that I would have
rammed right into him killing him and
far more tragically myself
but he didn't believe that I existed now
for him the other drivers are mere
Phantoms they're aberrations we exist
only in the theoretical he is the only
corporeal life form on the road which is
why he can do whatever he wants and be
as Reckless as he wants without fear of
colliding with another solid object
that's how he views it anyway unless
until he learns otherwise and learns it
the hard way and lots of people in
Nashville learned that lesson the hard
way every day
I drive about 10 miles to work and in
that 10 miles every day I pass three or
four accidents every day
and that's if the weather is good if
it's bad or even just mildly unpleasant
the highways look like The Walking Dead
cars and bodies littered all over the
place a truck flipped upside down
someone's Jeep is stuck up in a tree
somehow a guy in a motorcycle is like
dangling over the overpass
it would appear that as soon as the
first raindrop hits the windshield
people panic and just drive directly
into the nearest object
this is all very distressing for me
because then I am in the unfortunate
psychological position of feeling
annoyed at all these people even though
half of them may well be dead
I don't want to be annoyed at your pain
and suffering
I don't say I don't like that
but you're making me late for work
and you should have learned to drive
before you got on the road
yes you know yet this is this is all
really I think a preamble to my main
point I could continue complaining about
Nashville drivers for another 35 minutes
but I'm not sure how relevant that kind
of content would be to the average
non-natural citizen my main point is
this
I could run all the worst driving habits
on my local roads but none of it is
unique to Nashville
the volume and frequency is unique but
bad drivers are everywhere all over this
nation of ours and I have you know I
have I have to navigate around them
everywhere I go and the number one
habit of bad drivers everywhere at least
on the highway
is that they don't know how to merge
I was almost killed yet again this
morning by a bad merger which is why
it's top of my mind and I'll tell you
what happened
I was driving along on the highway
preparing to get off on my exit
see I'd already positioned myself in the
right most Lane because my exit was a
mile ahead and I wanted to be ready to
take it when the time came I didn't stay
in the left lane until my exit was 25
feet away and then attempt to cut across
four lanes of traffic I didn't do that
this guy was already in the right lane
before the exit comes
but as I was driving in that right lane
anticipating my exit somebody in the
merge lane entering the highway from the
entrance ramp just before my exit
suddenly jerked onto the highway into my
lane going about 15 miles an hour
I had to once again slam on my brakes
saving my life and undeservedly his I
then hit my horn in retribution and
shouted you know you dumbass learned to
drive or whatever but he couldn't hear
me no doubt he went on his merry way
oblivious to the fact that he just had a
near-death experience for this guy this
probably happens every day his life is
saved every day and he doesn't even know
it
now this idiot made the same mistake
that the majority of drivers who are
also idiots seem to make somehow you
know we require that new drivers go
through a driving test
but merging doesn't make it into the
exam
and the result is that the highway is
filled with suicide bombers and kamikaze
pilots who plunge into traffic taking
their lives into their hands every time
they do it
merging is an art almost entirely lost
in our world today so let me give you
the tutorial
when you're entering the highway
you will notice
that the other cars on the highway
they're all going fast
and this it would seem frightens the
average driver and so they come to a
dead stop in the middle of the merge
lane waiting for a hole in the traffic
not realizing that the hole in traffic
this is physics moves with the traffic
and they then insert themselves into
that Gap at a speed about 90 percent
slower than the rest of the cars on the
road
then comes the accident and people die
and worst of all I am inconvenienced
here's the way it's supposed to work
when merging into traffic
you increase your speed
go faster get up to the speed of the
traffic on the road you have a whole
Lane remember usually a merge lane will
extend for dozens of feet or more so
make use of that lane that's been given
to you for that purpose speed up pick
your spot seamlessly merge into that
spot while going the same speed as the
cars in front and behind you if you do
it correctly
nobody should have to hit their brakes
at all to accommodate you
if you're waiting for someone to let you
in thinking that you know they'll slam
on their brakes bringing traffic to a
standstill and roll out the red carpet
for you you're not approaching the
situation the right way it is your job
to assimilate yourself into traffic to
become one with the flow of traffic to
take your place on that Great Dance
Floor that is the highway without anyone
else having to break their rhythm
that is your solemn sacred
responsibility it's why there's a yield
sign in the merge lane not a stop sign
learn the difference
you suicidal maniac
now if all this is too complicated for
you and it is for some people
or if you find highways too intimidating
then stay home
save us all the trouble
save our lives and your own
otherwise I have no choice but to say
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
[Music]
foreign